[Musik]
die improvisation ist zentral bei helge
schneider
[Musik]
dabei ist er ein musikalisches
ausnahmetalent beherrscht unzählige
instrumente
[Musik]
muss man sehr gut sein um so
dilettantisch wirken zu können
ja schon als kind will schneider clown
werden und musizieren als teenie bricht
er die schule ab hält sich mit
gelegenheitsjobs über wasser
wie er in einem autobiografisch
inspirierten film erzählt astrid
schneider als jazzmusiker auf die
absurde komik gehört stets auch zu
seinem programm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einem millionenpublikum bekannt wird
schneider 1994 bei wetten dass der
abgesang auf seinen toten vater fritz
ein hack jahre zuvor entdeckt schneider
die liebe zum film
er spielt 1986 in johnny flash als
schlagersänger seine erste hauptrolle
sein regie-debüt texas lockt über eine
million zuschauer in die kinos die
presse ist entsetzt über das
improvisierte werk voll misslungener
tags seine skurrilen film figuren
tauchen immer wieder auf
helge schneider das original polizei wir
sind beruflich hier mein name ist
kommissar 00 schneider auch jetzt auf
einer pressekonferenz in mülheim taucht
er wieder auf
der kommissar
bald komme ich ja nun 00 schneider
was machen sie denn da was haben sie
denn die das geklaut nein nein das ist
doch für die tournee von helge schneider
die geladenen journalisten bekommen in
einem baufälligen hotelsaal mehr show
und klamauk den informationen zum neuen
programm geliefert
mülheim an der ruhr geburts und
rückzugsort von helge schneider hotel
handelshof ich warte zugegeben etwas
angespannt auf meine lang ersehnte
audienz beim meister
ich warte
wir besuchen schneider schneider haben
sie helge schneider gesehen haben sich
selbst verlaufen im hotel
ja ich hätte alle türen zu wollen
jaja und dtm
guck mal ein bisschen schweiz haben wir
für dich auch da wenn du mal da hinten
in cuxhaven schon ignoriert welcher berg
ist das ach so ich dachte die fahne
welche fahne ja die da draußen die
eu-flagge habe ich gar nicht gesehen
tatsächlich nein ich meine da hier die
dieses diesem bereich nach welcher berg
ist das denn möglich kopf privat egal
ich weiß nichts wurde ist ja warum
treffen hier hier aber hier so tradition
das hotel lebt somit so das leben das
ich kenne jetzt schon 50 jahre hier und
vor früher sah die welt natürlich ganz
anders aus
sie war vielmehr fluktuation auch
draußen viel mehr fußgänger pferde
kutschen handkarren da was formal noch
mit handkarren kohlen holen ich erinnere
mich auch an mich selbst ich bin
wirklich coolen holen gegangen mit der
hand karte
dort wird um zu hause kohlen zu haben
den ofen den heimgebrauch können sie
sagen woher ihr talent fürs
improvisieren ursprünglich kommt also
ich schaue in die zukunft ohne ängste
ohne sorgen und so kann man in kann man
eine gesunde improvisation auch
entwickeln das unternehmen sie denn
konkret dass da überhaupt für diese
chance auch genug raum bleibt und zu
improvisieren
naja ich probe so gut wie jetzt zum
beispiel unser bassist kommt aus amerika
und der kommt einen tag bevor wir auf
tournee gehen und dann habe ich gedacht
da würde ich aber nicht proben einen tag
vorher dann packen wir überein und
gucken was wir anziehen was wenn das
team das nicht kann
sie kann ja auch nicht vertrauen dass
wir das können natürlich ist in einem
kleinen team beispielsweise in einem
trio wenn dann wird schlagzeug bass und
klavier zum beispiel da ist es einfach
noch einfacher ist wenn gar kein bass
dabei ist das ist noch einfacher dann
kann man sich ergänzen am einfachsten
ist natürlich ganz alleine
[Musik]
shisha lounge ecke und dann hähnchen von
mädchen bekam ich mach ein bisschen
reklame hält in bäckereien will einmal
ruhig wohnen
liebe freundinnen und freunde und
schluss wenn ich mir dieses tourleben
vorstelle 40 jahre immer unterwegs diese
hotels dieses rumreisen das würde mich
wahrscheinlich generell irgendwann
leicht depressiv machen das ist zum
kotzen
aber dazu muss man auch mal kotzen
das ist ja nur befreiung auch aber
gleichzeitig ist das auch abenteuer
man sieht viel von der welt man sieht
auch andere fußgängerzonen die nicht
belebt sind man kann sich ein bild
machen zum beispiel über die
bundesrepublik kann nicht mehr
langsam bild machen warum manche sachen
auch so sind wie sie jetzt sind wo wir
auch vielleicht nicht mit zufrieden sind
und man sieht sehr viel da kommt man in
die schweiz
und da sieht man wieder ganz viel kann
man seine politik diskussion einer das
möchte ich ja nicht ich bin künstler
meistens auch nicht
ich bin künstler die kunst ist sowieso
politisch aber auf eine art und weise
da kann man also man durchschaut das
nicht so es ist eine gefühls politik
sagen ach ja sicherlich kann man sagen
ja schon das wort ja gegen alles man
soll sich nicht so ernst nehmen
das ist die eigentliche hauptbotschaft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die
wenn der mensch sich selber nicht so
wichtig nimmt da hat er viel mehr
möglichkeiten nach außen zuschauen auch
mal über den tellerrand zu schauen
das ist für mich wichtig ist teil der
ernsting unsinn
der ernst im unsinn liegt natürlich in
dem das der mensch der diesen unsinn
macht natürlich auch ein ernster mensch
sein kann
aber der ernst ist natürlich ganz
wichtig denn diese sachen die man zum
beispiel die ich auch auf der bühne
erzählen sie sind nur überhöht und so
dargestellt dass man eben lachen muss
weil sie so extrem überhöht sind dass
man denkt das kann ja gar nicht sein
[Musik]
tennis ass
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
machst du da noch oder ist das jetzt
auch schon überwunden ich muss immer
lachen ich ich ich muss immer lachen
also ich gucke manchmal hier in
deutschland gibt es ja die tagesschau
oder sowie mit oliver welke dem finde
ich unheimlich gut sind sehe ich
unheimlich gerne
für diese sendung auch gesprochen haben
und sie hat gesagt wir für sie ist das
eine ziemliche zangengeburt sein
programm zu schreiben wie gehst du davor
die geschichte ist die dass ich
improvisiere wir fallen sachen ein und
die verwerfe ich nicht die da arbeite
ich weiter an
also wenn ich jetzt asse broker muss ja
ganz klar sie muss das auch vorher auch
schreiben obwohl so wie es da bietet
hört sich so an als wäre doch gerade in
dem moment passiert das ist ja die
qualität auch und das macht sie
wahnsinnig gut finde ich ein kind zu
zeugen ist fast unmöglich außer man ist
15 und arbeitslos